It appears
we have some results.
Uh, this is very good. Look at this. We
have a couple of these runs that are
reaching 32K in one gig.
though. None of them reaching 65K.
Let's uh let's look at something real
quick. So
this 7 mil or 700K.
They're quite slow.
Let's put this on
score
and we got to get the correct metrics
out here.
Okay. Now score is very nicely
correlated. Right.
So now all we have is we've got time in
minutes
6 minutes.
What's in the box, guys?
Why is puffer so niche and underrated?
Industry experts know normies don't. Uh
because it's like the RL people on
language models are doing stupid baby
mode RL.
Like there's real work to be done in
language models, but it's not really
anything to do with RL. They have the
dumbest, simplest, easiest possible form
of RL, and they have a really dumb
setting for it.
I wonder if we have all the experiments
done yet. We probably don't, huh?
It definitely needs a big hidden size
though. Look at this. It's actually gone
and gotten itself 512 hidden dim
RNN args I don't believe are being used
anymore.
Then we do ve num threads equals
num buffers is actually set to one in
this 16k
Then we've got
a new beta 1 value slightly lower.
We've got a slightly lower beta 2 value.
Clip co is much higher. This is actually
a much healthier. Oh no, actually never
mind. That's a very aggressive clip co.
Not much healthier.
Uh this is normal range entropy.
small eps. That's fine. lambda is very
small.
It's kind of weird that we're seeing
these like very small lambdas
and these very high gamas.
Oh, actually I think I know what that
means. That's funny.
And then learning rate is this is the
main one
higher max whoops slightly higher max
brad norm
and mini batch size is the same
Oh, we actually have a replay ratio on
this one.
It's actually very nice that we have
this parameter in there.
We have our VF clip co.
We're not going to have to do this stuff
manually for much longer because um
constellation has a feature where you
can just click to copy everything.
Uh but it's not fully working yet.
Okay. And that's all the parameters,
right? That should be all of the
parameters.
Oh, you know why?
We have it capped to 1 billion steps
in sweeps.
So, this is probably Yeah, you see this
is out at 800 mil already.
So, that's got to be why.
Okay, I think that this is enough for
this sweep though.
This will be good for us to try out our
new bindings as well.
And that's still pretty quick. 2.2
million steps per second for 3.9 mil
per.
Oh, I didn't check numbum layers though.
Yes, I did. It was five. We're good. We
are good.
Hey, 24.
Okay, we did uh we did mess up the total
time steps here.
So, it's 730 mil.
What am I planning today? I'm going to
be cleaning up as much of Puffer Lip as
possible today. I want to start getting
as close to a release build. I think in
practice it's like these always take
forever towards the end. So, it's going
to probably be another couple months.
There are some bugs. Uh there's some
small missing bits. There's a bunch of
stuff I'm not super happy with the way
it's done right now. And we also are not
releasing before we have 100,000
experiments worth of data across all
ends with good sweeps, plus blog posts,
plus other stuff. But we're going to end
up having uh something pretty stable, I
would hope, towards the end of today.
You can all watch this run. This score
right here is the score in 2048. So,
you'll see this be super human very
quickly or super at least better than
you are.
Give me one second to grab something.
Actually, let's um
let's send this to Young.
Was enthropic done differently? Hey,
what do you mean that? What have they
done differently? Nothing.
You flooded the internet with shitty
abs.
You'll see our
our latest run
Look at this.
Here's our new run.
We're going to let this finish just so
that we have this uh benchmark. We're
going to commit these nice new params
up.
and then we're going to start on the
major refactors for the day. But this is
a very nice result to have overnight.
Take a look at this.
There's rocks.
I mean, we can pretty well see if we
just put it on this mode.
Like, was it this is 17K.
Um,
well, you can't fully see actually that
more compute equals more performance yet
because it's capped on steps.
So we will fix that.
And this is like
super solid result.
This is not even with the custom
network, by the way. This is
I think I kept their Did I keep their
encoder at all? I think I did keep the
encoder. We're going to go check.
I'm pretty sure I kept just the encoder.
Okay, let's add the new config again.
Whoops.
I don't think we have that in um
I don't think we had that result so
quickly before.
This is nice.
Now we can start on
The real work for the day.
Let's uh let's come up with the plan.
So,
we cut out all of the very easy to
delete code last night and we made one
major major enhancement.
We actually solve both of these.
So like remaining refactor.
I just want to figure out like where
where the complexity remaining is.
I think I can do this from here. I think
it's going to be like let's move ocean.
I'll start on this. I actually really
don't know what what we're going to do
specifically on clean up until I get
more into it.
And now I'm looking at it. We got a lot
of stuff cleaned up yesterday.
I think that the safest initial bet
though is
one real quick. Whoops.
I don't need this. This is a super
simple
That should be like several hundred
lines from model C++ into ocean specific
code.
And what will the remaining complexity
be after that? I wonder
Muan for sure.
Muan gets cleaned up.
That mock just goes away. So that file's
gone.
Squared CU goes away. We're not have
that
advantage stays for now
and then realistically there's just some
small cleanup in models
uh followed by
I think the main bulk of the rest of
it's just going to be in puffer lib C++
right like there's a little bit to do in
module
But I think then the most of the cleanup
is just going to be pop for lib C++.
And that's not even super messy as much
as like there's some stuff that's in
there that needs to be elsewhere. And uh
there are a bunch of the functions that
we've graphed that are a bit confusing
and there are a few redundant bindings.
So I don't even think that's going to be
that hard. Like we actually now that we
fixed the main bloat jank thing uh that
was actually the main complexity believe
it or not like most of the bloat of the
library was there. Now there's also
there's some numeric crap where like the
kernels are a mess. So we probably want
to clean up our kernels.
Have you noticed a difference?
No. Honor, I don't want these. I like I
don't want to like be more and more
reliant on the models being smarter.
Look what I just had it do.
I literally just used it to copy some
code around.
Like that's it.
It literally just It's not writing any
new code here.
I just had him use I just used this to
move some code around to new some new
files. um
because I figured it would also get the
includes
like realistically if this were C, I
wouldn't have even done that, right?
Because like I just don't know what the
hell the includes are with torch and
CUDA. I would have just copy pasted it
myself.
and actually this is taking too long to
have even been worth it frankly though I
did get a couple minutes to sort of
think about the rest of this in the
meantime.
We definitely have some bloated kernel
logic and kernels we really really want
to be clean. I think this is the most
valuable piece of code ultimately that
we'll have in puffer. Uh we'd like the
graph tracing thing to be relatively
clean as well.
And then the there are a few other
things that are relatively easy compared
to those. I think those are the two big
ones.
So these just get moved.
I wonder if it deleted my comments.
That'd be hilarious if I go and I look
and it's like deleted all my comments.
Would just delete blood.
and actually it's going to be more
because this is now going to come out
of. So look look at this from before.
And now we've taken like 300 lines out
of models. This is now a reasonable
Oops.
Yeah, this is now going to be a
reasonable enough amount of code.
Uh we've got ocean, which is now
440 lines.
okay so models back to seven okay that's
good but that's a reasonable amount of
Yeah. And then this no longer needs
these jank headers because it's just
directly in the CU. So that's actually
going to make it shorter.
use the rest room. I need a few minutes
and um
and then I think we'll start on either
the policies or puffer lab C++ one of
those. I'll be back.
Same speed as before, right? 14 plus.
Very good. Very, very good.
670ish
lines.
Let's take this one.
So, we're not even sure if we're going
to keep this one here at all.
Put this
underneath mini grill
this whole thing.
I'm going to put our default encoders
and decoders up top.
Hey Jess,
are we cleaning stuff up right now?
That's what we were doing.
Yes, we got like 100 something lines of
extras bottom
logs. Very nice.
Let's start looking at what we actually
have here.
This is how mix precision works, right?
I'm pretty sure. Yeah, this is. So, we
have it correct here, then.
Like, if you've actually ever talked to
any of the anthropic people, they are
insane.
It was truly just all the crazies
leaving Open AI.
A lot of them truly mean well, but
they're just like
they're incredibly incredibly out of
touch people
trying to like define the future, but
they have absolutely no grounding in
reality.
I'm looking at this. What do we think
about this?
I don't think you're going to see too
much AI coming out of Europe.
Even something like this looks kind of
gross to me.
Am I being overly uh overly critical
here?
If I just do this, Hang on. Does this
still work if I just convert this to an
int?
Oops.
There's something weird with torch on
this.
This should still work, right? There's
no like requirement that the signatures
be um
I just want to try something real quick.
I think that there is a torch API
requirement that like you can't use ins
or some build like some weird [ __ ]
I want to see if that's the case. It
might not be.
I could do this with um I could do this
with just like Vim find and replace, but
uh there's a greater chance that I screw
it up by like miss messing up the um
like you know something else already
exists. It's called hidden or whatever.
I guess. Then the question is going to
be on the signature. We need to figure
out the signature in the meantime.
I have it at the moment I believe. So um
the Python version can return a
distribution.
Yeah, sadly there's still I'm look the
more I'm looking at this, there's still
going to need to be some plotting
horseshit until I get rid of um a few
more Thanks.
The other thing I'm not sure about
um so folks if you're going to look at
this right we have
we have conditionals on this seek length
is one this is the eval path versus the
train path and then we additionally have
the kernel versus non-cernel path
Okay, this is at least somewhat cleaner,
right?
The way that uh C++ handles class
variables is a little annoying.
Would you explain what this code is
doing? Uh hello, welcome. I'm Joseph. I
work on Puffer Puffer LIIB here. This is
the fastest reinforcement learning
library out there by a very wide margin.
We have a whole bunch of demo
environments here. Lots of games, but
also drones, driving, and more. Uh I
stream all the development. This in
particular is me working on cleaning up
Puffer 4, which is our new release that
introduces 14 million step per second
training with a a custom C++ backend,
custom kernels, and more. And I'm
currently working on cleaning it up and
removing some of the jank uh that uh was
sort of associated with development
here.
That's like one startup in SF
that France. Yeah,
I know. The startup stuff has been kind
of ridiculous lately, though, man. Um,
like the thing you have to realize is
uh raising around like that's not real
money.
You know, if you raise $200 million, you
don't just get $200 million. You've
essentially taken out a very high
interest forgivable loan that you can
only spend on the company.
Check the website. Yeah.
Hey, that guy.
Oh, hey. uh that guy. There's there's
one really awesome thing I came up with
yesterday that I think you might you
might appreciate this. Um
check this out. We have no templating
garbage and no required launch functions
for dispatch
in any of our kernels.
you just compile the build with -bd
precision because 99% of the time you're
going to be using bflat 16 and you
pretty much only ever need float if uh
something is numerically unstable and
you want to test. So you just can
recompile with drecision float to test
but other than that you just have like
cuda c and this removes a thousand lines
worth of dispatch and templating and
garbage.
Look at that.
All the kernels are just like this
with a precision T and that's it.
RTI, you're not gonna if you're using
RTI,
what do you mean if you wait if you're
using RTI
runtime type information? No. No, dude.
It's compile
It's You see
it literally just macros the type
previous implementation. Yeah.
Well, I had to go through a couple of
iterations to get here, man. And then I
had the insight at dinner.
Oh, a Torch uses Wait, Torch totally
uses runtime type information though,
dude.
That's how they do it. They have a They
have a dispatch macro that's conditioned
on the tensor dype. I'm pretty sure
it is technically fast regardless though
for us because um every you got to
remember everything gets cudographed but
yes there will be a small performance
hit for um non-cudigraph
Oh, yeah. Another I got one other thing.
You may or may not know this. Um,
I couldn't reach your ex via J Suarez
5341. It's J Suarez now. I got uh X got
me uh hooked up with the the handle
without the numbers
wants to run the model in BF-16 and the
optimizer in FP32. That's how we do it
anyways, dude.
Like the like the mode that you would
obviously want to run it in is just the
mode that we already have.
It's a uh it's accumulate in FP32
with a f with a flag that you can set to
go to to a 32. And if we wanted to add a
different precision, it would be like
two lines of code change.
I do have one question for you actually
on architectures. I don't know if you've
ever um if you've done much with these
uh what are they called?
What are the mamba like uh state space
type models? Um hang on.
Do you know
if this expansion factor thing matters?
This expansion factor param.
The idea is that they uh they can
project to a higher hidden dim and then
do everything and then project back at
the output of each block
beyond my knowledge. Cool.
I don't I can't see any reason why this
would matter. So, I'm just planning on
not including it.
Like, I can't see why it would be
useful.
I suppose I could.
It's kind of annoying though because
like we'd have to change our kernels,
dude, cuz it puts it puts an extra layer
before the output gate.
I'll think about it. Maybe I won't
delete it just yet.
Oh, yeah. One other question for you.
So,
I just want to bounce some stuff off of
you.
So,
do you have a Python mode that would let
you run quick ablations? Yes, I do. Um,
they're not quick though because you
literally lose 5x perf when you go to
Python.
That's how fast Puffer is now.
And also torches, like if you try BF16,
um, torches BF16 is not stable for this.
our numeric are now better, which is
pretty awesome.
Like obviously if you think about the
design, our numeric are going to be
better, but it's still pretty awesome to
see.
Uh the one other thing I wanted to run
by you.
So apparently this thing lets you run
matt moles without a kernel launch. like
you can just do kublas map mole inside
of a kernel.
So if this exists like
what is the point of us having like why
wouldn't we just write the entire
network in CUDA
like this was the only op we needed.
How new is it? I don't know
like realistically though this is super
simple right like Nvidia has a kernel
and it's not open source and they expose
the host API so like
if you just copy pasted their kernel
code to the start of your kernel it
would do what this thing does.
So, I'm just wondering like with this,
can we not just write our entire
networks in CUDA now?
Isn't that way better?
Like, it's not any harder, right?
CUDA is C. I like C.
Presumably
you have to set up a little bit just to
get um debugging working, but
like instead of having the stupid bind
to module and then invoke kernel, it
would make the code shorter too.
I don't know. I added Peru in the
Discord. I don't know if he replied. I
figured he would be a good person to
look at it.
supports the narrow use cases. I don't
have narrow use cases, man. We got
pretty broad use cases.
model arch.
I mean this is not a trivial model
architecture at all.
What I mean like
if there's an Nvidia uh an Nvidia
attention kernel for instance that's not
supported in this you would mean
like yeah but then you just go back to
the old one right you just like whatever
is the operation that you need the host
call for you just take out.
So you basically just fuse the entire
path of stuff that is supported and it's
still like incremental uh improvement to
simplicity.
I mean, you see how annoying this is,
right? Because like literally we just
need the maple code.
I do wonder if you can beat Nvidia's map
for like smaller matrices. probably not
right.
They probably actually bothered to tune
it for even small mass.
I don't know. I'm partial to Nvidia. I
think of all the big companies, they
have the best engineering.
We're mostly just cleaning up puffer
today. I deleted 3500 lines of garbage
yesterday.
2K were stale code, but like the rest of
it was actually
simplist actual simplifying improvement.
You wouldn't see things like flash
attention.
Let's grade. I don't know if this is
best. But this is also the template
library, right?
I pretty much just want like my the more
I think about it, the more my ideal
library is just like uh kernels.cu,
right? A bunch of kernels with the code
and not like launch functions exposed
actual kernels exposed. So you can just
like call the kernels from inside of
other kernels
which essentially just means like raw C
that like it's just C for GPU
and just eliminates a lot of the
[ __ ]
on specific hardware. Fair.
They don't do more RL producing. Uh they
do just I've actually I've heard that
there's some uh some stuff that they're
doing that probably using puffer.
So I think that there are at least some
people there that are aware of it.
I wouldn't mind. Nvidia could choke us a
nice contract. That'd be good.
and we we're pretty much just doing
stuff for their chips now, right? With
um with Puffer 4. My assumption is that
like most likely Nvidia is going to
continue to have the best hardware and
the best interfaces for everything. And
even if they're not, like um I would
hope that any useful chip has a
low-level interface similar to CUDA
anyways, so the port wouldn't be bad.
I pretty much have no interest in um in
TPUs. Uh if they're intended to just be
programmed with jacks, that's just
that's completely unworkable.
If TPUs had a CUDA like interface, I'd
be way more interested, but they're not.
So, Nvidia hardware good.
Like realistically, you don't even need
the entire ecosystem
with XLA. Yeah, but XLA is not human
writable,
right? It's a mess.
In my mind, that's just fundamentally
the wrong design.
You can't have the low-level interface
be something that's not human readable
and writable and then have [ __ ]
Python be the uh the actual interface.
Yeah, but XLA Torch XLA is a backend,
right? It's codegen. It compiles to that
and it's super slow as well for small
models and you have basically no ability
to do anything about it.
because you don't have a CUDA level
interface
like you don't have something on that
level
like look how simple this is right
look how simple this is
this is like a fusion of 20 or 30
operations
If you do this in naive torch or naive
jacks, even with their compile modes on,
which will take forever to even build,
it still produces way slower code.
So like why would you spend your time
banging your head against a highle
framework when you can just write out
the ops? Uh, and it's just fast. Like
you don't have to get the compiler to
produce the correct ops, you just write
them.
This makes way more sense to me.
Okay, let's see if we can get We have a
couple decisions to make and actually
we'll be taking suggestions from chat
here on what to do about this. Um,
the first thing I really hate about this
is how we're handling mixed continuous
and discrete
or how we're handling continuous versus
discrete.
which is completely unnecessary. I think
expand as is this a view up.
See I do I trust this to be a view? A
new view with singleton dimensions.
Okay, it is a view op
does not allocate. Okay, so this expand
op is actually not that bad.
I thought it was just copying like in
memory repeatedly.
But we probably have to call contiguous
on this with our kernel. No.
Let's go see how this works with
training
discrete categorical continuous.
So you get logic reshape log std.
Oh, you do end up with log standard dev,
right?
Wait, but this thing is never um h
I don't know how much I care about
optimizing the speed of the continuous
path at the moment, though. To be fair,
we literally have one continuous end and
we're not even sure if continuous is a
good idea in general for action spaces.
Like multi-discreet is way faster now.
Oh yeah, that that was the white whale,
right? That guy. Like multi-discrete
sampling is just super fast now. Look,
I'll show you how easy it is. It's
actually faster than the expanded um the
expanded uh single discreet by far.
It's right here. just this.
Okay, maybe not just this. This is still
a fair bit, but it's it's just a loop
over numbum actions and then the
individual op.
Yeah, that should be no overhead and
good
to relatively small
improvement.
Because even if I have two separate
pathways, right?
And I think we can have this be null
now.
So this is the first pass, but I think
we can have this just be null. Like this
tensor be null instead of empty.
me. I'm going to reshape.
Let me make sure it's not screwing us up
here.
Okay. So, I think that this will be fine
for this. Um, do people have ideas on
what to do? The next thing that we're
going to have to fix after this is going
to be this kernel path here. Look how
gross this code is because there's a
different path for training and eval uh
eval and training and then there's also
a path for custom kernels versus native.
So, Do people have ideas on that?
And then we're going to build squared
continuous,
like if I go for live ocean.
Yeah.
How is the process from removing the bad
code? It's going
What do people think? Do you like the
way that this looks?
That's the main one. Jess, I want 50 to
be a smaller algorithmic update where we
just check a couple exploration things.
I have one other exploration project
going on that's not public because it's
an academic collab that could very
easily make it into Puffer 5 as well,
but it's basically just like a couple
projects around exploration and pure
algorithmic improvement. And uh the main
thing that matters for those is going to
be having a good number of useful test
MS that we can run very fast and stably.
Chest will be a very good one.
When is the paper coming out? Uh,
there's no draft of a paper yet. It's an
active project. We don't have results
yet. We do have some like pretty cool
initial stuff though.
Should have more on that collab in a
week or two as well.
Okay. So, that took a little bit, but I
think this is decent now, right?
Do you always prefix your bulls with is?
It seems kind of dumb to me.
Uh, I think I'm going to have about
$1,000 in anthropic bills for the month,
which in the scheme of things doesn't
matter, but is incredibly stupid.
because like you'll hear like, "Oh,
$1,000 like it must have been really
useful then." But like practically if
this thing if uh something makes me if
something saves me 10% time even if it's
just by automating the really really
stupid parts of my work like um really
obvious refactor ops that's easily
$1,000 worth right there right no That's
like the price I paid in token is not
really a good reflection of uh of much
of it being smart at the least.
Okay, next thing is going to be Oh,
let's actually make sure this works.
Let's not jump the gun.
Codex and chat.
The token limits are really [ __ ] though.
I don't ever want to hit token limits.
like I just use the API and I stick a
100 bucks on it every time I run out of
credits.
Okay, so we have
the next thing is to figure out how
we're going to change this
mining grew layer. I think this is going
to be
actually don't we have policy?
Yeah. So, this should go this needs to
go down or this needs to go up in the
code.
Let's that way we get the full picture,
right? Min grew.
Where is it? Min.
Yeah. So, let's look at how much code
this is, right? So, this is pretty much
the entirety of Puffer 4. Like this is
the heart of it here. Um it's this OP
in your contracts that they pay for
credits.
Uh no people don't like that type.
People like when you just give them a
price
like our prices will just increase over
time. Guess
nickel and diamonding people is not the
way to go in business.
It's like when you go to a nice hotel
and everything is like twice the price
it should be for like basic amenities.
It's just like come on,
okay. This is not as bad as it looks.
The reason this is not as bad as it
looks, I believe we should have this
logic down here.
Can I not just if I copy paste this up
top? It's the same code, right?
Yeah, we've got some duplicated code,
so this will look a lot simpler.
These checks are already done.
Oops.
And then this goes like this, right?
Boom. Boom.
That looks good, right?
Hey, Liberty.
Oh, and look then now this is also
uh this is also redundant now right?
What were the results of the training of
our sweep overnight? Really good.
So, we have uh a
six-minute
uh 1700 some odd score run.
No, 17,000 some odd score run. Excuse
me. In Breakout, no, not breakout. Ah,
2048.
So, that's really solid. Uh, now we have
a way better run in Puffer 3, but it was
run for much longer. So, I need to do
like a much longer experiment with this
and probably longer sweep, but like for
a first overnight run, this is about as
much as I could have asked for. And it
replicates as well. We retrained it. It
replicates.
Oh, wait. You can't do this because All
right.
Yeah, that's kind of what I was
thinking. Okay.
Yeah,
it literally is
This is kind of confusing though. Don't
you agree?
Read all 330. No, that's not my like
that's too broad of a domain, man.
Uh, this is very good. I actually
haven't read this. We do not use
transformers in our RL stuff.
Uh,
How many of these have I read? This,
this,
I think this one.
I don't know if this is the same one I'm
thinking of.
Yeah.
This one. This is the course. This is
the good course.
Well, I This is very much LLM pill as
well.
I think you miss a lot a lot with this.
Like there's some stuff in here that
doesn't really matter too much.
And this is very um
very LLM pill.
Actually, it's not even. It's kind of
like a It's a weird transitional list.
When was this? Oh, two years ago.
I mean, I have my own list for RL in my
article, right?
How long does it take you to read a
paper? Uh, it depends how much I read
it, man. It could take three months to
read a paper or it could take like five
minutes to read a paper,
you know,
I actually learned yesterday apparently
Ilia was the one who um
wanted OpenAI to go all in on scaling
though I heard that secondhand. I don't
know if that's actually what it was like
the actual quote
I think these turn errors are kind of
crap. What about you guys?
Hey guys, option A, B, or C?
What do we think?
we could also do there's there's a
variation on this. We could do
I think this is more complicated to read
though, right?
A or C.
Yeah, I don't like B. I think this is
too much
to one line it.
and then I there's going to be another
opportunity I believe and get rid of
this expansion factor thing because we
don't support it anyways
Now that I'm looking at it
Good.
I think that's good.
I don't know anymore, man. They've all
gotten too big.
Despite all my criticism about OpenAI
nowadays, I've been very public in
saying it's the best place I've ever
worked. When I was there and it was 100
people, it was awesome.
Like it made Stanford and MIT feel like
a bunch of drooling idiots by
comparison.
But now it's a thousand plus person
company, right? Like you don't maintain
talent density at that scale. You just
don't.
Hang on. This has forward and forward
train anyways, doesn't it?
Let me try this first.
Make sure I didn't break it. I probably
did because it probably is like going to
have expansion dim or whatever in it.
Math it's figured out during learning
and doing stuff.
Uh it just it depends on what your focus
is, man. My work is way engineering
heavy, right? Like at least 80% of my
work is uh engineering.
I understand architectures,
right? I understand the core learning
algorithm I'm working with. I even do a
little bit of algorithmic work, but it's
like 5% math for me.
It's mostly
How much is basic requirement?
uh you definitely need to know math at
the level of CS231N
which pretty much you need to know uh
the chain rule for partial derivatives
and you need to not go nuts when uh
occasionally a matrix get gets flipped
in and gets transposed in the
derivative.
Sometimes cross terms but usually not.
That's about it.
It's not really that serious of math.
It's certainly a Let's put it this way.
It's a lot less math than you needed for
uh machine learning before neural nets
came about.
Now, look, if you're going to tell me
that you're you want to specialize in
diffusion, that's a totally different
story.
like general engineering math is also
helpful.
But in my view like the majority of
progress being held back is by people
being bad at engineering, not being bad
at math.
You can go to MIT. There are a whole
bunch of people that are really good at
math. There actually comparatively very
few people who can just program stuff
that is not awful.
I don't necessarily think that you need
to be smarter to be a good programmer
either, but it's a very different way of
thinking
and it's a way of thinking I very much
enjoy. Programming is very close to just
logic to me.
Um
I don't know people say like writing
like clear writing is clear thinking.
This is like that except without the
whole [ __ ] psychology element where
clear writing is actually not at all
clear thinking and you can kind of lie.
That's fine.
Do you think in language or visual?
Uh
it's mostly symbolic.
I don't know.
Hard to describe.
How do you end up in more engineering
than programming? Well, I started I
started learning a bunch of math when I
was getting into research and it was
really hard and it wasn't actually that
useful and then I started doing some
engineering and it was still kind of
hard but it was really useful
and then I just kept following the
gradient of what was useful to my
like simplicity is
simplicity is not really subjective.
It's only subjective within a small set
of bounds. Most of of good engineering
is about uh making hard things simple
like making complex things simple
like for instance right
this versus the oneline version of it
there's some subjectivity
uh but this versus the original there's
no subjectivity right the original I had
like three times as much code as this it
was worse this is now better there's no
subjectivity in the matter
and then you're going to see like the
code will just be objectively better by
the end of the day.
Did you ever feel stupid at MIT? No, the
opposite, dude. I got there and it was
like, wow, all these people are really
dumb.
Cuz OpenAI was way, way, way, way better
than MIT. Same for Stanford
because I did you know I did six month
internship at OpenAI. I like finished my
last quarter at Stanford. I graduated a
quarter early. I was working on my
research independently for like six
months before I started. And then it was
like wow this is really not actually
that great.
There were a few cool people, few very
smart people.
Um, but it was nothing like uh it was
like nothing like what was at OpenAI.
But like think about it, man. How the
heck am I going to get to MIT and feel
stupid when I'm there to do research and
I'd basically already spent the last
what I start PhD at? 21 22. So I'd
already spent the past five or six years
of my life full-time just doing
research.
How much was paid during your intern?
I think it was like 140 annualized,
which for an internship back then, they
actually surprisingly paid more than um
more than like most of the uh like the
bigger tech companies did for interns.
This is back before money dropped like
by 2x in value, right? Like your money
like everything was half the price back
then. You got to remember the uh COVID
era inflation was just utterly stupid.
Like lunch in California back then was
seven bucks.
Clear your debt.
Uh I don't I did not have debt.
And generally loans are like far less
common at the top universities sfing
in the US.
Are they pay less? No, they just don't
have internships. Not officially at
least. Who saw you more on Sam? I never
saw Elon at OpenAI. I don't know if he
was still there. I think he was already
out. I don't actually remember. Uh Sam
gave a couple of the all hams.
He said some good stuff, but I I
couldn't read him and I didn't really
trust him, and that was apparently
proven correct. Um
Greg and Brockman were very smart. Uh a
couple of the younger people there were
awesome, like Alec Radford was awesome.
Uh
there were a few other people there that
were just like really good. Oh, some of
the people on the Dota team were just
very very smart. Like they had figured
out stuff in RL that uh pretty much the
field still does not realize
for the most part
scholarship. No, SFAN the way it works.
Um so pretty much the top universities
in the US if your family can afford it
your family pays. uh otherwise you get
need-based uh financial aid. It's not
like a scholarship thing at the top
universities.
If you get like into tier 2, then that's
when people start taking a lot of loans.
Who can lift the most at OpenAI?
Brockman.
Totally. Brockman.
Well, it depends what you mean lift the
most. He does Olympic lifting
so it's more technical but he is in very
good shape.
How much research done in open AI was
published when I was there? Uh I would
say that the vast majority of research
done was published
almost all of it.
It was very very cool.
That's like the thing that that's why I
wanted to be there, right? Like it
wasn't because it was a nonprofit or
whatever. I didn't give a [ __ ] about
that. It was because it was published
if open continued on Dota 2. Yes. Uh
OpenAI like they set back the field of
RL by a decade by not continuing on the
Dota stuff and at the very least like
not releasing it fully.
Family play. Yes, that's thing. I'm uh I
mean I was very fortunate in that
regard,
but it is the case in the United States
at least that if you are smart enough to
go to a top university, you're not going
to be saddled with a ton of debt,
at least most of the time. There are
some exceptions.
Um I believe like if your family has
money but won't pay and then you don't
get financial aid and you have like
there can be weird stuff like that. Um,
but for the most part, like
you're pretty well off and also at the
top places anyways, if you're in a uh if
you're in a good field, like you'll pay
it in a year or two anyways.
Uh, the student loans being like really
really crap is more so for
uh not the top universities or uh fields
if you're in a field that does not pay
particularly well.
GDB. Yeah,
it's cool.
Who can run the fastest opener? I don't
know.
No idea.
I'd say most of the people there were
not in particularly good shape. Most of
them were like very scrawny academic
types.
I was back then as well. When I was
there, I weighed like 135 maybe 140
pounds.
All this training was uh during my PhD
and like since then
how can people survive the work
intensity if not in shape?
Um,
it's easier when you're younger.
Like, you basically have a you have a
span of years from 18 through early
20sish or 16 to early 20s where you can
kind of just get away with it and drink
a lot of coffee. And then after that,
it's like, no, you got to be in shape.
Who's the most handsome and open AI?
I don't know, man. Ask a woman.
I'm not uh for evaluating
men's appearance. Thank you.
You know, same same journey like
Netscape.
I mean, I think OpenAI will likely still
continue to be worth a lot and make a
ton of money and like have a bunch of
deals and build some LLM stuff, but
unless they massively pivot, I don't
think that they're on the path to just
solve everything with Chat GPT7.
I think that they really really [ __ ]
up by abandoning their RL core and that
knowledge is now gone. like the people
that are doing like that knowledge is
gone essentially. And I think it would
have been lost completely if not for
what I'm working on right here. That's
why I'm doing it.
Now, the trade-off is they're no longer
going to own this, right? This is now
just going to be out in the open.
Everyone will use it. It'll be good.
Best current lab?
Funny enough, probably Deep Mind.
I think they're the only ones that are
still actually considering a whole bunch
of different problems that we can solve
with different methods in AI rather than
just like you know going all all in on
language models and hoping that builds a
machine god. Like there's they are still
doing a lot um on language models but
it's not just that and that is good.
I mean, a good thing for science, right?
I don't know if it's a good thing
financially or business-wise. I don't
whatever with that, right? It's a good
thing for science
is what I mean when I say that type of
thing.
Keep this minded Google. All right,
enough with the silly questions.
Uh, survive the AI bubble burst. I don't
think that there is a there's no AI
bubble. There's a little bit of an LLM
bubble. Okay, a lot of an LLM bubble.
Uh, there isn't an AI bubble. I do hope
that when like people realize they're
not getting their money back on some of
the LLM investment, um, I do hope it
doesn't have a ripple effect and kill
off a ton of other research. The cool
thing is I'm kind of insulated, right?
Because like I'm not in a space where
I'm burning tons of money doing this.
I'm kind of just doing my own thing. So,
at the very least, I can sort of just do
this indefinitely.
Frankly, if it does, if um the LM bubble
does burst, it'll probably make it
easier for me to pick up like some
really really good people that are
looking for something new to work on.
I don't think like the average OpenAI
employee is good enough, but I think
that they have they do have some
fantastic engineers and researchers
there still, even if the talent density
isn't as what it was.
But there's also like a very specific
type of person I like to work with as
well.
Okay. I kind of like to work with people
that understand what are the right
problems to be spending their time on
and like when they get stuck in a rabbit
hole, it's going to be a rabbit hole
that actually has some chance of being
broadly useful and not just like, "Oh,
this is an interesting puzzle for me to
solve."
Until when do you still accept M for
Puffer 4?
uh until pretty much right before Puffer
4 launches,
standards too high.
Not really. It's just it's impossible to
scale. Like it's impossible to be hiring
hundreds of people in a few years and
still have talent density.
It really just depends on your mental
model. Like in my mind um engineering
and research skill it's very very firmly
exponentially distributed right where
like
a really good researcher is worth
exponentially more than a mediocre one.
You can get good very quickly though if
you have the mind for it.
I'm kind of been thinking about how I
want to look at this, right?
How do I get good quickly? Follow RL
guide. It's worked for others.
I mean, there's something of a mindset
thing, right? Like
you understand what problems you want to
work towards. You understand what tasks
are likely to actually move the needle
towards that or not. you understand what
things you need to learn to get there
versus what things are likely to be a
waste of time.
It's only 100 200 people who matter and
make a difference. Yeah, that's fair. I
mean, it's really
it's the thing is AI is now broad enough
that it's probably more than that. Like,
I would believe that in LLM
specifically, it could just be a couple
hundred people really uh doing anything
that's super useful.
selfplay.
Do you think we should go? How do you
think we should go about? I don't know
how you're doing it exactly, Jess.
Why don't you raise from VC? You can get
50 mil seed. Uh, I'd have to probably
get a couple co-founders additional to
bring on for that, but like I don't want
it, dude. That like what does that do
for me?
Like think about it. What does that do
You don't just get 50 million for
yourself. It's like that's not how it
works, right?
Like do you understand what that
actually means?
like that means I can hire 10 people for
maybe four years. Um, I have a whole
bunch of strings attached to me on like
what I'm actually allowed to do and how
I have to go about things. I have a huge
amount of overhead in management and in
communicating [ __ ] with VCs that prevent
me from being deeply involved in
day-to-day work where my skills are
actually best used.
It's more than just giving up a part of
the company.
I don't really think it does 24. I think
actually it dramatically decelerates my
own research and basically just it's
basically on puts a lot more of the onus
on who I hire I'm hiring.
Like I've spent a long time getting very
good at my own individual dev, I can
make a huge amount of difference as a
single individual. So like basically
replacing half my time with management
is not a good tradeoff.
And then plus putting a ticking time
bomb on like a long-term research
project for running out of money. Like
it's just a bunch of stuff is not worth
it in my mind. I'm really happy I'm
doing stuff the way I am.
Like I pretty much I'm pretty darn
confident I'm going to have RL set in
the next couple of years anyways
opposed to having founders. Oh, that I'm
not necessarily opposed to
though. I'd rather be with people I've
already worked with, you know?
Like I don't really I don't think it's a
good idea to go get random people.
I just said like to get 50 million I'd
have to go do that.
Like I could go get 10 or 20 without
doing that.
What would you need to know? Probably
can clarify.
I guess I would need to know
specifically how it is you're like using
the other policy for the 20% of data and
stuff. Jess, you've kind of seen me
deving this stuff, right? Like is it
just adding some logic to the C++ and is
there a way we can do this without
messing up the non-selfplay path?
speed up for research if people founded
VC's managing. I mean I get lots of
emails 24. I mostly ignore them now.
I spoke with um while I was in
California just for the hell of it cuz
like I got a few good ones um uh
messaging me. So, I had a few meetings
and there was one woman who ran like a
small firm who I actually really enjoyed
talking to. Um, Pokcoa actually. She was
like really really good. Uh, but all the
big ones like
holy hell,
it was just not enjoyable.
I mean, like literally,
I would go sit down and talk to them and
they'd be essentially trying to figure
out my angle with the whole open source
thing, right? Like they basically have
everybody reduced to purely maximizing
dollars and not giving a [ __ ] about
anything else. It's like, you know, if
you could legally pivot to selling
fentinol, like they'd be all over it. It
was that type of people.
How many VCs really understand tech?
Some of them sort of do.
There are a couple that are actually
fairly technical, but like
no, I don't want to be beholden to
people anymore, you know? I just I want
to do my own thing. I'm very good at it
now. I'm doing it very effectively.
No, I don't I don't want more [ __ ]
right? I don't want more noise.
Like just the clarity that I have now
over research is so valuable. I want to
keep that and I want to keep going on
that.
Okay, let's see what is what's happening
here.
think that this is like Whoops.
I don't fully like how this is
This is actually not bad.
And this is still fast, right?
Yeah. Same speed.
Bad perception of open source. Mhm.
I guess like
I know I suppose lately I just have this
model of the world where there's so so
so much noise and actually a lot of the
problems you don't need money to solve
them like you don't need a team of
geniuses you don't need 20 years all you
need is to simply take a step back from
all the noise and look at the problem
and just start solving it in the
simplest way possible
and you can make a huge amount of
progress
and you can make stuff exist that would
otherwise not exist. It's incredibly
important that it does exist.
Yeah, this is mostly just a bunch of
checks.
to MIT. Um,
the MIT people were technically better.
The Stanford people had a little bit
more perspective.
It's better.
You meet Feay.
That was my first internship. I I
interned in Fe's lab when with Justin
when I was in high school.
I actually met her recently for the
first time in 10 years um
over the summer at um at a new company.
I happened to be in the area so I just
showed up and I was like, "Hi."
They work crazy hard.
No, I don't think most labs, it's not
like everybody works crazy hard. Like a
lot of the pressure in um a PhD
environment is self-imposed. So there
are usually some people who work very
hard and some people who don't.
Carpathy and Justin were both pretty
obsessive about stuff.
Olga as well was um I remember Olga was
there working on the imageet challenges.
It was pretty cool.
haven't even been married, haven't they?
I don't know.
I mean, I not all of them are going to
be posting stuff over socials. If they
have
which they're students.
No, it it's really individual.
Like my advisor pretty much just let me
do whatever I want I wanted. I mean, I
did work fairly hard for at least a good
number of those years on uh on their MMO
and stuff.
I probably work a little bit harder now
than I did during most of my PhD,
frankly.
And I'm definitely way more productive.
most PhD work is not useful. Most
industry work is also not useful. Most
work in general is not useful.
supported by grants. Yeah, all PhD
students pretty much are supported by um
by grants.
Your professor goes and gets some grants
and then sticks you on some grants that
are like vaguely related to your work.
I think it's not bad.
This is definitely getting closer.
And then what we're going to do, right,
is like we can even add the LSTM as a
back end for comparison if we feel like
it.
If they let you do whatever then they
might not get uh the so the degree to
which the grants have influence over
your work depends on the lab.
Um
most like talented PhD candidates though
are not going to sign up for a program
that pays them 30 to $40,000 a year to
be like told exactly what to do for five
or six years.
That's just not how it works. So,
I mean, like, think about it, right?
Like, hey, like you're smart. Want to be
paid some peanuts to be told what to
like to work on some stuffy thing that
you don't care about for some company
that's paying like a fifth of what they
would pay you if you were just working
at there in person.
No.
Wow. Really? Why not?
So, usually there's, you know, you find
a professor who has an area of interest
that matches your own and, you know,
you're the agreement is that you're
going to be generally working in that
area of interest.
Some professors have specific projects
that they want people on, and they say,
"Oh, yeah, we're hiring PhD students."
Um,
most are not that way, I would say.
Well, I it depends. It really depends
from university to university and such.
It depends on the or
I think the people that do um like the
half at deep mind half at Oxford or
whatever like those are pretty good
to work only for the company to say nope
you can't publish this. Yeah. So
straight up um at MIT like they you
can't agree to take work with those
restrictions
a lot of the uh the good labs and
universities like the professors are
literally not allowed to take work with
those restrictions.
How useful is research from the
university? It depends right.
It depends vastly on the project on the
student and on everything. It can be
tremendously useful. It cannot be same
as everything else.
No claw today.
Yeah, we've still got some shitty
refactor ops. Unfortunately,
it's all gross C++.
Uh the one thing I will say is that uh
in the process of doing this there's
less and less gross C++.
So so far today here this is what the
decoder looks like now. Not bad.
Um this is what mining group currently
looks like for the multilayer one. I
think I can clean this up still a little
bit more. And I want to clean up this
policy, but we've already were minus
like minus one class minus a decent
chunk of code.
I mean, it's mostly the fact that
everything looks like this in C++,
right? Like look at this crap.
I would like to get rid of things like
this.
I think this is a torch thing though
that it requires shared pointers.
How do we get continual learning?
I mean, honestly, I think I think the
problem is kind of poorly framed
in the first place.
Like, people sure as hell don't solve
continual learning.
Okay,
let's see what we have left.
We do get a single policy out of this
which is very nice. The Ford just
becomes this which is very nice.
You removed my torch tracks, you
absolute [ __ ]
Let's make sure this still passes and
then we'll figure out uh the next set of
fixes.
This is where we want to spend most of
the uh the policy effort I would think
is on just having a really clean base
policy.
Animals are dumb and a bad way to do
neural nets.
You need if you have an alternative, you
also need to be able to have hardware
that works for it.
It is entirely conceivable that you come
up with neural nets based on a different
operation.
Uh it's kind of meaningless if you don't
have hardware that implements that
operation efficiently though.
Okay, so two screens of code pretty
much, right? Two and a half screens.
I still think it's worth putting more
effort into making this thing less jank
because this is if anybody is going to
be reading the policy code, this is the
main chunk of code that they're going to
read.
And I don't want them to look at this
and be confused. I think that this
should be like the super simple
thing.
Let me use the restroom real quick. I'm
going to grab myself a mug of tea and
we're going to continue on this. I'm on
all day. Like I got another six, six and
a half hours to stream.
I'll be
Evolutionary evolution is kind of a
meme, dude. Like,
I'm just going to go mark a bunch of
things I think that I don't like.
Catching.
That's funny as hell.
mo is a long project. We still use it.
There will still be future versions most
likely.
Stanford is dope.
Yeah, I think it is the best place for
undergrad.
You can make yourself absolutely
depressed. All you have to do is take 22
units of uh you know of well real
classes uh in the winter.
If you don't do that, you're pretty
good.
Project is very good. Like what?
How does puffer box thing work?
Personal GPUs to test on. Uh we have
like 10 desktops. We allow uh
contributors to gain access to them, but
we don't give them to just new
contributors, right? like you have to
have actually done something that
demonstrates that you're producing
something that needs compute for
experiments. Otherwise, everybody would
just be asking me for uh for access and
not actually do anything. You do also
have to sign um for access you have to
sign a a ULA that says you won't do bad
things on our cluster
and then you just get direct SSH to a
box.
Has Docker set up already in it. Boots
you straight into the container with
Puffer already set up.
Well, maybe it's not bad. Actually, this
kills this cast and this cast.
And then what we in order to do this we
have to
What's the rent? Just rent the GPUs.
Wait, what? Rent the No, I own the GPUs.
Crit.
Um, we have physical hardware.
You can rent on vast. Sometimes they
mess with the machines a bit. Uh, we
thought it was better to just have a
bunch of boxes.
All robot learning labs in one pit.
Oh, yeah. They do have that, right? I
don't know. I haven't really been over
to the robotics people much.
A big AI big envir neural MMO is a big
AI environment. Yes. Hey, user.
Does anybody understand this specific
piece of C++ jenk?
Like why
why does this cast exist?
I think I'm looking at the code and it's
like the structure is mostly fine.
There's just little bits of littered C++
junk here and there
that we just don't need to deal with.
That's the main thing that's bothering
me.
So, let's say that we finish this up in
the next 20 30 minutes and we're happy
with this.
Probably I can have it port the LSTM as
a backend just for fun to see real
quick.
We'll take a quick look at this stuff. I
think this is mostly fine.
And the rest of this is pretty simple.
This is a quick clean up. So, we'll be
done with the models file in like an
hour tops.
So we just don't use module list in C++
then.
Required Polymorphic module share torch
register
modules needs it. Annoying
Yep.
This should be substantially simpler
and then this int update.
Okay, now we get to look at what we have
again.
Yeah, that'll save quite a bit of um
Yeah, that'll that'll make things a fair
bit shorter
including like this should just be a
little bit more readable.
Oh, cuz it literally just ran a play. So
full.
Make sure this still works. And then
let's see what other jank there is to
remove.
Okay, good. Works now.
So, we got mini grill.
Which existing end has the most
expensive step function? It's probably
something stupid like um
connect four. No, maybe go. But it's
probably one of the MS that has a stupid
scripted built in.
Most expensive usually just means least
optimized code though.
just have flood plus. Uh, no, I'm just
using the API at the moment.
power grid ops. You need Yeah, you don't
want to have um you don't want to do
that. You don't want to have a first end
with an expensive step. You're not going
to have fun.
initial state of batch size.
And you can use this with whatever
I messed it up somewhere along the way.
No biggie.
I'm just not seeing this. This is super
basic, right?
Oh,
right.
forgot about that. That's super obvious
as well. I should not have forgotten
that.
I thought you could do equals equals
like
Yeah, that was dumb.
I think I just have to figure out what
torch checks I want
and then we're mostly done with Yes.
You actually don't use B anywhere, do
you?
Yeah. So, you don't use be anywhere.
Okay.
There's no reason to have these
be new line when they're such short
functions
Don't know how we want to format that
yet.
we know the required input side the
input shape here
and then what we need
So I think pretty much then
it's pretty much set
X and state
And what's this forward train?
Oh, no RNN, I suppose.
I don't think I particularly care about
this, do I?
Yeah. No, I don't particularly care
about this path
because we're just going to do the
sampling different
like we're going to assume it's segment
level.
We're just going to assume
TT is just going to be
size to one.
This is getting to be very very clean
though.
Getting to be very very clean.
I don't like that we have this reshape
here.
But I think this is We're going to have
to refactor when we do uh the rest of
this stuff.
I think for the first chunk this is like
really really solid progress. Look at
this.
This mining grew
We're not going to spend time on the
LSTM stuff until um we fully have the
policy done and then it's just like
going to be an automatic quick refactor.
So, we don't even have to worry about
that.
What I do
Make a quick commit.
This works.
It does. 14 mil.
Cool. And uh that's also minus some code
apparently.
So we just deleted another 500ish lines
for refactors.
Super nice.
Now let's do
Let's just look at the rest of this real
quick. So, we have I think that was the
main code, right?
No, that's the main code.
Um,
so now I got to go look at
I got to go look at Puffer Lab CPP and I
got to see
used
All
in. Okay, so this is just like directly
taking it
sample actions and write directly to
rollouts
It looks like these are getting
flattened.
Wait, is it
now I'm getting confused. So,
logits meanreshape.
No, it's getting reshaped to a sequence
value.
Why would I do that?
For advantages probably, right?
Right. So it's a little bit annoying
then because
the decoder is meant for flat data. The
encoder is meant for flat data.
But during training stuff has to get
reshaped, right?
That's moderately annoying for sure.
Uh, I'm trying to think. Is there a way
around that?
I don't think so.
Let's take one more look at this and the
whole thing
minerals.
layers equals one.
It's fine
D type
device.
Interesting.
Got your torch. Check.
Select the state.
Get combined.
Okay, I definitely want to look a little
bit at this logic.
Is there anything else in here?
This is pretty simple.
Uh, what's this? Parameters.
This is weird, but I think this is for
Vflow.
Okay,
this is pretty tight. Then I think that
we don't
Let's not agonize over this more right
now because we're going to learn other
stuff from uh refactoring the rest of
this. We're going to ignore the LSTM for
now.
Do I want to do this first?
I think it's policy next. Not policy.
Popper lib C++ next. Right.
There's a lot to do in this file
actually. Let me get a little bit of a
sense of it.
I mean, it's just stuff like this,
right?
Yeah, I'm going to do the same thing as
before.
Yeah, this is going to take me some work
today.
Let's just get the easy stuff done
first.
Yeah, this is just a whole lot of crap,
isn't it?
Remove state zeros and reward clamping
is sketchy.
Big labs hiring high school. s
um
they're mostly memeing hiring high
school grads, frankly.
Like as someone who started research
really really early,
um
even if you've worked very hard and
you're very smart, you just have not had
the time to like learn stuff reasonably.
Some undergrads can be pretty good.
Like it's one thing if you say like,
"Hey, uh, we think that this guy is
really smart, so we're going to invest
in this guy and we think that he'll be
good in like two years." Like that's
really cool to be giving people
opportunities to do that, but like I
there's just no way you have the breath
of experience
um by that age. And I say that as
somebody who like really really worked
hard and I was damn good for my age,
right? Like I was already doing some
research, but like I was just missing so
many things back then.
Rest of this is going to be harder,
right?
Okay, I just went through and did like
some of the really obvious stuff.
We start with 1116 lines.
Probably not going to cut a lot of
lines. 45 KB.
It's probably going to make um it's
probably going to cut some text out
though.
Yeah, that's good.
That's good. That's kind of what I was
imagining, right? You just do like cuda.
Yeah.
I don't know. Maybe this saves a KB or
two.
File size obviously doesn't matter. It's
just about the amount of code you're
freaking looking at.
There's like little crap everywhere.
Okay, so just off of a um like a very
quick
redundancy thing.
See how many tokens we saved or how many
um
how much order this file is.
Most of it is just that. That's the only
little bit of dead code to be deleted.
Think maybe that and a couple lines of
profile.
So we are going to lose like a I don't
know 20 30 lines worth of the refactor
is going to be moving
moving this function
mean
but I think this will be
tries to macro [ __ ]
No reason.
Okay, so 45 KB
down to 43.
A little shorter.
still have a massive pile of crap to
deal with.
I'm trying to think what the best way is
going to be to piece through this.
Okay, we still train, right?
Yep. Super fast.
I got to think about where I want stuff
to live. There's too much stuff in
puffer lib C++. I think there's just
like
I don't want to have like torch utils or
something. I also don't want a ton of
little files. Let me get a refresh on my
key and we'll continue.
Yeah, I still don't know what to do
about the um
about this. Like there's just a bunch of
stuff that's
there's a bunch of stuff that doesn't
fit clean lane.
Let me scroll through this real quick
and eat some soup. We'll uh we'll figure
it out.
The graphs
buffers hyperspel
Actually don't think this one gets used.
Does it?
Maybe it does
forward call
graph.
Okay. I mean, I think most of the code
in here is devoted to
it's like all split up for graphing is
the thing.
They're really they're only a couple
little things that um that don't super
belong
like this clip norm and stuff
my soup and we'll think about what to do
about this.
I don't typically eat much during my uh
my long stream days.
I guess one question is why do we have
so many different little split out
functions in the first place, right?
We got train graph. We've got
roll out buff.
End of buff.
That's it. Right.
So why we have so much stuff?
Oh yeah, it does. It gets used in this
callback.
So we just kind of have too many places
where this gets used, right?
you can't just write the logic top to
bottom
because of um
because of the cudographing.
Well, here's something. We can split all
of these out into
all this stuff for the most part can get
split out into layers,
I would think.
Yeah, we basically do the same thing
that we did with um models.
Let me just have it do um
do this while I am eating
this logic.
This logic.
So that's just some redundant logic
right there.
We also have just have too many layers
of this crap.
Okay, this is substantially better,
right?
Fine.
Hello, web GPU.
So there's pretty much no more policy
logic in here now, right?
Yeah.
So on one hand that is um that's good.
It's now nicely and pretty succinct
uh in models.
On the other hand though then if we now
have a thousand lines of stuff that's
like what is it doing right?
I mean, this could go into the models
for all I care, right?
But then that still leaves us with like
900 some odd lines of crap.
So, what's all this crap doing?
Okay, we've got end creation. That looks
pretty succinct.
We've got train graph creation.
Got roll out buffer. This is the
experience buffer. This is all the
experience buffer logic. It's very nice.
We got all our hypers. Okay.
We've got paparel.
Maybe has a few too many things defined
in it.
Probably has a few too many things to
find in it.
Here's fused rollout step.
So, uh, this doesn't actually really do
anything given that all the logic is
here. So, why is there so much code?
Let's figure that out. So, this thing
gets graphed.
Let me see cuz we have our conditional
kernel stuff on this, right?
Like let's say that we can get this into
a separate file.
Then what are we actually looking at
here?
So you have to select the chunk of
each of the output buffers.
this these calls are just really
freaking verbose
is the problem. I think
like all these if you're looking at
these these are just copies and they're
really long because select narrow copy
it like
h
Let's keep reading. I understand at
least where the complexity comes from
here.
And likewise here now it's the same
thing.
Why is there so much cleanup to be done?
So you have to understand that um porch
is an absolute disastrous mess.
It's very very difficult to write good
clean code on my first shop uh when I'm
also working around
like pretty much everything revolves
around being a total disaster.
Most of the stuff I had to figure out is
not even documented anywhere at all.
I also just have a much higher bar for
what I'll share
with that complexity is to look at this
creation function.
So this is our graphing stuff, right?
No, we got continuous discrete here.
This goes into ocean.
This is BF-16 an optimizer.
Here are all the buffer allocations.
This is definitely too deep. Like the
logic is nested too deep.
Okay, this isn't implemented yet, but we
need these.
Quite a bit of logic.
All these profile tags.
It's going to be pretty difficult to get
this cleaned up.
I mean the main problem here right so
anything that needs to be profiled has
to be split out into a separate function
anything that needs to be cudggraphed
also needs to be split out into a
separate function
So we have two different things that are
requiring us to separate things behind
function boundaries
and then also pseudograph versus
noncudograph is separate. So we have two
different things requiring us to split
things out into separate functions. And
we have two different things that are
requiring us to have separate pathways.
Oh, yeah. Also, there's There's the call
back thing because um the back end has
to own a call back.
There just lots of different things
requiring me to split stuff up uh in a
way I normally wouldn't want to. That's
pretty much all there is to it. As for
the reason why it's like this now, how
we get it to not look as bad, that's
another question.
We got our models very nicely cleaned up
at all.
I think puffer lib C++ should be this
should handle the cudigraph pathway
and then anything with if kernel should
handle
Anything
This should go into um
into model C++.
How would I get started on chess?
I may try to implement.
No idea on that one.
I'm running an 8 by8 by 64 off
for target locations.
isn't it? 409 40
4K babe, right?
That's kind of like the highest you
possibly want your ops to be.
Can you not just pack that into 8 by 8
by two and have it just like one hot?
You can, right? Okay, that's fine. 8 by
8 by two is fine.
That's good.
It's simpler than what you did in
Pokemon, isn't it?
That's a pretty simple encoding to try.
Oh yeah, by the way, I don't know how
well you did on um 2048 before. This is
from our first sweep that we ran on it.
So, we've got to uh 17k in 6 minutes
No, like I mean I don't remember how
quickly the models got this for is what
I meant, but there
it's pretty
embeddings with Rubik's
do not just solve Rubik's instantly.
Okay.
I would figure that would be an end that
would just insta solve.
Let's give it a max solve time
and you initialize with a random number
of scrambles.
Okay, so we have a whole bunch of these
now that take a million different things
in them, but this is a start.
So now if the models files responsible
for um custom kernel versus not
Okay. So,
this is the actual logic
for the most part.
So, why do we still have
967 lines in this file.
And now the actual meat of it is this,
which is really it just looks much
longer than it is because of um the
torch C++
copy syntax here.
Like this is just
Yeah, this these lines should be half
the length.
What about here?
Forward train law giant function sakes.
That's silly.
What the syntax? Yeah,
I'm basically just trying to figure out
where all the bloat's coming from, man.
Like, this is not a trivial thing to
build. you have uh you have stuff that's
forcing you to split stuff out on the
kernels boundary. So kernels versus not
kernels and then also on cudigraphs
versus not cudigraphs. And then there's
also this annoying call back thing for
the endback
sizes should be checked at file time
What is Okay, here's another question.
What is the minimum number number number
of layers we could theoretically have
for this thing?
So, there's got to be a train function,
right?
Inside of that, there's a portion of the
training that it can be that can be
graphed. Presumably,
anything that has to be graphed, you'd
have to stick behind a function
cuz there's not really without having a
specific function to graph, there's not
really a way to do it.
So I think you have to have
you know train logic logic logic if cuda
graphs graph replay else whatever
the else also has to be a function call
because it's the same logic you're
graphing Okay.
And then inside of that
you have a conditional on custom
kernels, right?
The custom kernel is going to be a
function call.
And actually even the other path has to
be a function call because you need like
that logic needs to be on its own so you
can test it.
So you need to have frame like you need
three freaking layers at the least.
And then of course kernels goes to
modules goes to kernels is five layers
deep. That is awful
overhead or stack death. Uh I'm worried
that deeply nested li like deeply nested
libraries are just kind of [ __ ] It this
is not about compiler or anything. This
is just it making the code less [ __ ]
we have like train
right and then it's like
frame function
and then in here we have frame function
And then we have if uh kernel
train kernel
else
train
native
and then we have like
uh frame native
which is like
actual
logic.
And then you have
And then this has
um launch.
Was it?
This is like so giga [ __ ] because like
if I want to see what where's the train
code, you have to do like if okay, not
this one. So this one. Okay, do I want
the train front? Let's look at the
native one first. And then you go here.
I mean, I'm trying to think maybe I can
do.
Can I do this?
See, I don't think I can do this.
But like I don't even think I can do
this man because practically the graph
path comes from tracing one of the other
paths.
This is not like as trivial as just how
do you break up if statements normally
like this is not as trivial as the
normal thing is.
And the problem is that there's like
usually even more rapper logic in here.
if you duplicate a bunch of logic for
these
modeling it like a state machine help.
No.
Let's look at what's in here.
So this train forward PS gets graphed
for example right now. All right.
The only other thing I could see to do,
I'd have to change the whole way I
capture graphs.
So
the way that you delete this layer,
you have to the the problem I think is
the fact that we have
we have this additional layer that's for
graph capture basically right like this
function exists why does this function
exist it doesn't exist for any reason
other so than so that I can capture it
in a graph
There's not really an easy way to do it
otherwise though. You need to warm it up
and [ __ ] No.
It's pretty tough to figure out a better
way to do this.
I'm getting freaking cudographs, man.
That is eventually what's going to
happen.
This is a judgment call, but in my view,
the freaking code is too deeply nested.
I don't know whether I will like this
more.
sets it back to the default stream is
okay.
This actually does let you immortize the
uh the chapter iterations as well, which
is nice.
That's probably worth doing it alone,
right?
plus side. This gets rid of all this
janky graphing logic.
I suppose we could break things
potentially here.
I don't know. This is fine.
What do you look for in a good
environment? Can you describe why 2048
was surprisingly useful? Um because it's
a very like fast end that's easy to
understand what's going on. And we were
all surprised to see that it was
actually quite difficult and it scaled
very well with compute. So this now
gives us a pretty solid benchmark
uh for a reasonably large runs where we
can see like okay before we solved this
thing in an hour with 10 billion steps
and in the new update after changing the
architecture and rerunning our new
sweeps now we solve it in like five
billion in half the time or whatever.
So just the fact that it's actually a
reasonably difficult task uh that is
fast and that scales well. I mean it's
also not like artificial difficulty in
some sense, right? Like we know that it
has a reasonable encoding. We know that
it's not like just trying to understand
pixels from scratch.
It's just like a straight exploration
problem.
If puffer solves it instantly, would
that be a waste of time? Uh, I mean, it
could be a cool environment, right? It
could be cool that puffer solves it
instantly.
Like for instance, I think most of the
bosses in Runescape, uh, which are very,
very difficult for even experienced
players to learn, I'm pretty sure Puffer
would just oneshot them in a minute.
It would be a really cool demo. It
wouldn't be like a super useful research
environment, but it would be a really
cool demo and a nice sanity check, I
suppose.
But definitely, yeah, overall um
environments that have meaningful
difficulty, and you do need to make sure
it's actually meaningful difficulty,
right? Um
those are pretty good.
Like an example of a very bad
environment would be um you write get
guess get a password. you like write
like the password is whatever uh in
pixels and then you have the environment
have to enter the passcode. Like that's
a really stupid environment, right? It's
really easy for people. It's really dumb
for the agent. Well, a lot of the RL
environments out there are actually just
that in disguise.
another good sign is like um relatively
fast environments
where progress is still uh indicative
of performance overall.
Like we do a ton of our basic
experiments on breakout and breakout
seems to be the minimum complex the
environment for which usually if stuff
is better on breakout it's generally
better everywhere.
Not like perfectly consistent, but
pretty consistently.
This might be the environment thing.
Unfortunately,
stream A captures with this.
You probably just have to synchronize on
capture.
We can we can definitely mess with that
though.
Wait, what?
Yeah, this is not how um
Oh, yeah. This is fine actually, isn't
it?
Yes.
But wait, we do synchronize. That's
weird.
Oh, well, they're going concurrently.
That's the problem, right?
That's got to be the problem. They're
going concurrently.
Yeah, that's moderately annoying. All
right, I'll be right back.
Why is it just chilling here for like
five minutes?
Let me see if I can think about this.
So, we launch
Drop pool sharing entirely.
Each craft gets its own private pool.
Why are simpler M still useful? They're
faster. Neuralarmmo takes um currently
the best run we have takes three days on
six GPUs.
And you know, we'd like to run a
thousand experiment sweep over it, but
that's kind of tough.
We do have another out to this, but it
will slow the first few iterations down.
If you had a lot more GPUs, then only
complex MS would be useful. Not exactly
because scaling is also not free, right?
Like when stuff is slow, it also means
you need heavier infrastructure
in order to uh to run the number of
experiments you want. And heavier
infrastructure is more prone to being
buggy and screwy.
So like it is very very worth it to just
put in the effort to make everything
fast and simple.
It's like really provides you the
highest confidence and easiest way to
reason about stuff.
It would probably shift the top end of
research right towards the more uh the
more complex ends. But like
you don't really want to be running all
of your experiments on a bunch of
hardware taking a bunch of time.
Like ideally what you want to do is you
want to run really fast experiments that
are uh strongly indicative of
performance on harder ends.
It used to be an RL that like um you
know you would have to do all your
experiments on the target end because
otherwise
you'd run your experiments on whatever
and then nothing would ever work on the
other end that you wanted to get it to
work on. At some point Puffer just got
good enough that that stopped being a
problem.
Is it because we're using the same
stream?
Are we using the same stream?
We probably are, right?
Wait, we shouldn't be right. Capture
begin.
per buffer pools?
I think that one is okay.
might be a memory. Um, it might be more
memory. I don't know.
I mean, this whole way that we're
graphing this is kind of ridiculous.
Anyways,
Maybe we have to wait for the M to be uh
ready.
Sorry for the questions. You're good. I
wouldn't be streaming if I didn't want
to, you know, answer stuff from the
chat.
If I sound irritated, I'm irritated at
this thing.
I'm trying to think. What do we do about
this?
Super annoying.
we need these dreams
before we can do anything.
12 to go until 5,000. Folks, please star
puffer live on GitHub. 12 stars to go
until 5,000.
I think that this is going to be
irritating fighting with these um these
graph captures, but if we get this to
work,
uh it should dramatically simplify this
file, I would think.
Like there's a whole bunch of other crap
to deal with in here.
Okay, all this stuff is going to get
pasted in place now. So, that's chill.
Well, I think I actually have um I've
got a way to do it. It's just going to
be a little bit slower for the first
epoch.
this is not even going to be that bad
because you don't need it for the
warm-up its right.
Yeah, this will work.
I think so at least if we do them
sequentially.
Okay. So if we do this sequentially
then
that's a lot of the jank gone.
We still have way too much freaking code
Uh it didn't actually update it. All the
right function
which will be at
Okay, I see why it failed to do that.
It's still easy though.
Yeah.
Okay.
I think that this can actually be set to
equals equals.
And I think that That's the uh the trick
is we're going to be able to set that to
equals equal. So it's only one epoch
that's
Oh, wait. We are training with one
buffer.
All right, we're good.
That's within uh noise.
And I think we shouldn't even need chat
mode anymore, right?
Oh yeah, that's faster. That's where our
speed went. Good.
Nice.
Uhoh. Are we uh worse now?
I'm stuff.
I'd say most of the people around do um
ends the core you need to have more
lowle background
cuz it trains with one buffer. So
there's definitely um
definitely a dip, right?
Yeah, you can see it there. It's
definitely broken with this.
TUI is beautiful. This
Thank you.
I uh I spent a little bit of time on it.
It's just from uh it's still with rich.
It's not in the C++ unfortunately.
That CL code are terrible. They are
terrible. Alan
graphs are definitely screwing with each
other now.
Okay. So, one buffer trains, right?
Of course, one buffer trains.
How would this be? I mean, they're
clearly
they're doing something at the same time
as each other.
Anybody have any ideas?
We've got multiple threads like CPU
threads that are running multiple
buffers.
This should be doing them parallel
though
and then capturing when synchronization
in between.
kind of weird.
Let's go look at what this is going to
be.
I think that this is worth it if we
figure this out.
Device sync. Something's not syncing.
So, the reason this is going to be so
good is
we're going to basically just be able
ignore all this garbage, right? Um,
we're going to be able to have this
code, no, this code get inline.
So, we're not going to need
like more and more functions.
so much work
to get this good, but I think it'll be
worth
only one graph at a time.
Multiple buffers replay concurrently on
the shared pool.
There's no concurrent replay, so it
works.
only one graph at a time for a shared
pool.
Actually, did we do all the captures on
the same pool? Let me look.
Looking to build a more complex end that
isn't trivial and active PR. I mean,
there are lots of them.
Generally you want an interesting
problem that you have some expectation
that um you know there'll be scalable
difficulty to it.
To give you an example uh one of the
recent ones that somebody did uh Tim
started building so and I look at it and
go oh actually wow that's a perfect
environment. I don't know why I didn't
think of that before. Right.
Where's this?
Come on.
Multiple replay buffers. Multiple
buffers replay concurrently on the
shared pool.
So, I mean, we can test this pretty
easily just by stashing and um
and just trying to train with like 20
buffers, eight buffers or whatever.
That would suck though because that is a
that would be a perf head.
Could a doc say one graph at a time for
a shared pool
which would make sense.
Wait, we did find num buffers equals
one. And um
Oh,
I could have actually messed that up.
Yeah, I could have messed that up,
couldn't I have?
That would be a bad bug,
huh?
And then that would account for
variance, wouldn't it?
Well, if that was the bug, then it's
amazing that it was working at all. I
hope that's not it. Sincerely, we will
see in a moment.
When graphs from the same pool execute
concurrently,
their private allocations can
aliasization.
Okay, hang on.
Be very careful. Get staff.
Old
place.
Yeah, that's 16 mil SPS, my guy.
That's stable.
That's a 3 second solve as well.
Um, okay.
Well, the good news is we do not need um
we don't need this. It's some bug. We'll
figure it out.
And we also have that's a 3second solve.
So,
we are absolutely going to be able to
solve Breakout
um even faster than we have.
We have a very very nice speedrun
result.
I have no idea why this is the case
though.
It's got to just be something due to
like creating the other frames.
should be synced though.
Model architecture ever change. I mostly
see the same in grew stuff. Well, that's
a brand new architecture in 4.0. So,
yeah,
we used LSTMs in Popper one, two, and
three.
So, this is like a brand new
architecture that we've been working on
the last couple months to get into here
stable and fast. Um,
aside from that, I only have seen the
40. Yeah. So, I mean, that's going to be
the base of the architecture for
everything in 40. You can add your own
in. It's going to be swappable. Um, but
that's it seems pretty darn good to us.
You can add in custom encoders and
decoders.
Most of the time you don't need a custom
decoder. I think a few M's are going to
want custom encoders. It's mostly if
they have like um you know weird
observation shapes or stuff needs to get
one hoted or stuff like that
which decoding part decode just means
it's not language right decode here just
means Map hidden state to actions,
actions and value.
I'm trying to think what would be the
difference here.
Like the network shouldn't be getting
cold
until everything else is synchronized
in the sequential mode.
It's going to be so nice when we
eventually just drop for and we don't
have to do this anymore.
just like no cuda graphing 15 mil per
second training plus
spend a lot of time in search space for
kernels
I need using their beam stuff
so I messed with tiny a lot I liked what
they were doing uh their kernels were
And they're not human readable at all.
And they're also for a specific size
only.
Like it's a hard code to do a specific
size.
So I don't see how we're supposed to use
them easily. I was going to try to pull
some kernels out and like I spent a
little bit of time on it and I just
couldn't find like a nice way to do it.
Like presumably, yeah, we can make it a
lot faster. When do your temperature
shapes change? I assume that's what you
mean by size. When you run with a
different hidden dimension or different
OBS dim for different ends, right?
I mean, we'll run the goal here is we're
going to be running sweeps of a thousand
experiments. And the sweeps include the
number of layers, the hidden dimension,
right?
You search during the runtime for a
given config size.
Yeah, but like how on earth do I do it
with their stuff, right? Like it would
have to be it would have to every time
you run at least for all possible sizes
potentially if like all new experiments,
it would have to go run this slow beam
search for that and then it's going to
generate a completely non-human readable
kernel that's for one specific size.
I've tried they do have kernels that are
per variable size. They're still
completely non-human readable and they
were very slow when I tried.
Search happens as part of the runtime is
it it's way too long. Oh yeah, the
kernel search. The kernel search is
going to take like 10 times as long as
the entire training takes for our test
ends.
For our bigger imps, maybe. But it's
still so freaking heavy and clunky. And
I honestly I just hate the idea of
having Kronos not be human readable.
Yeah. I mean, if you look at our kernel
code, it's like it's going to be so nice
and easy, and we're going to be able to
build so much stuff on that. Like,
that's pretty much the only thing I'm
actually happy with at this point is
having these like nice fast, simple
kernels.
not doing any search manage. Yeah, we
haven't done any um we have not done any
kernel search at all yet
and we're already at like 14 plus mill
steps per second.
So
I mean this is what happens when you
overly extract [ __ ] right? Like
you just completely lose sight of the
problem.
Most of the kernels are not that
complicated. A couple of them are a
little iffy, but most of them are just
not that complicated. And like
apparently nobody bothered to check
baseline perf on any of this stuff.
How good is 14 mil? So, okay, for
context, um, Puffer Live was
state-of-the-art in 300 with 3 to 5
million steps per second training. Most
libraries out there are training at
10,000 steps per second. Uh there's some
high perf ones at 100,000 and then there
are like a couple that are kind of
cheating and using dumb dumb
architectures and stuff that maybe get
like hundreds of thousands up to maybe 1
million. So we were already
state-of-the-art by uh like 3 to 5x or
more and now we're up from that to 14
million with uh it's like a small model.
It's only 200k per but it has memory.
It's a four layer min. It can solve a
lot of the simpler RL problems in
seconds and trains 14 million SPS
without even going to ridiculously large
batch sizes.
Dumb architectures. It's not a dumb
architecture.
Oh, dumb. No, no, no. Like no memory. A
lot of the like the a lot of the RL
libraries that say that they're really
fast, they're just using an MLP. No
memory.
It's really easy to optimize that crap.
But like those models are just not
useful.
What's an example of one of those
libraries?
completely stupid model,
completely unreadable code. Look at
this. Seven layer deep nested function
defs and uh runs on only runs on
completely trivial look. Yay, vectorized
cartpole completely trivial jacks.
And look, they're bragging here about
having um what's this? Minute, which is
a really, really stupid simple breakout
in five minutes. We have it now in five
seconds.
What are you doing? High performance RL
seven layers of functions. Yeah, this is
why the Jax people are just batshit
insane.
Like, it's not even fast. It makes a
total mess and it prevents you from
throwing it on like actually interesting
problems.
I don't think you can capture on the
main thread, can you?
Like if you need to jit your Python, you
probably just shouldn't be using Python.
I hate that we even have to graph
MLP imply no memory.
It's another MLP. It doesn't work.
Yeah, that just doesn't work.
You need at least some sort of
reasonable gating mechanism to make
effective use of memory.
There's pretty much no variation of just
simple MLP that actually works.
capture on the main stream. Is this how
we're going to do it?
completely stupid.
Yeah, these models are just not capable
of reasoning.
They really aren't.
Does anybody understand what the hell's
going on? So before what I did is I uh I
pre-traced all of the rollout graphs
before I created the environments. The
environments have a couple of CUDA
streams associated with them because
they manage their own async copies. Um,
now what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to just use the first few its of
learning as the warm-up
uh and then trace it after like after a
few epochs
which should be faster.
The problem is that somehow wires are
getting crossed and it's letting me
trace uh but it doesn't learn like with
multiple buffers when I do it this way.
So if I do this with one buffer it works
but if I try to trace with multiple
buffers it doesn't work.
I tried like running the buffer serially
still doesn't work.
No idea.
Photograph's kind of evil.
Let me use the restroom real quick and
get another cup of tea.
right.
What? How is this stupid thing still
spinning?
Let me try to figure this out.
Me try to figure this out. So,
Capture
stream management
cuda stream
begin crap here.
All operations pushed into the stream
will not be executed
will instead be captured into a graph.
Capture may not be
initiated.
Capture must end.
Oh,
but then you would only you'd lose one
editor.
We can try this real quick. I don't
think that's right.
I think we've got Oops, though.
I'm realizing that this graphing is also
going to mess with our profiling, isn't
it?
No.
We can just we can make the profile
start after graph capture.
That's not Yeah, that's a very minor
thing to have to deal with. That's easy.
Let me think. If this doesn't work, what
do we do?
We only have two places that we have to
do this at the moment.
completely broken.
Lovely.
Absolutely lovely.
Photographs. Incredibly obnoxious.
Incredibly obnoxious, I got to say.
Did I put on the website? I don't think
I remembered to. Did I?
If this doesn't work, we're going to
have to figure out what the hell else
because I I'm out of ideas after this
Yeah, torching cudigraphs is like
completely evil.
Nope, still completely broken. Lovely.
And just to confirm,
Ah, great.
Well, this completely screws us.
Oh, lovely.
Uh, we get to deal with the billing tax,
the anthropic tax.
Realistically, I should just build this
directly to meta because this is um
torch being a piece of [ __ ] is what this
is.
Like the reason I'm even having to do
any of this is cuz torch is piece of
[ __ ] Um,
$100
anthropic tax.
This will definitely work at the very
least.
It's um we don't get to get rid of the
capture logic at the top. So, we're
going to still have that jank,
but we won't have to have uh like the
super deep nested
calls.
So, that's not bad.
We'll do this.
It's four.
I'll apply all this stuff.
We'll see if we can get the puffer lib
C++ implementation into a reasonable
spot. That's a good goal for today.
We'll basically we'll have done the
models file and then the main puffer lib
file today. And then we'll have saved
modules and kernels are going to take
additional work.
So, if anybody is wondering, no, 4.6 is
not magically capable of reasoning.
It's not capable of much of anything.
But I'm still stuck using it because
this is undocumented hellful mess of C++
garbage.
I'm going to be so happy when we just
have everything in plain CUDA Cuda C and
I no longer have to do this. That's
going to be great.
Okay,
let's see if this is done correctly.
This should be very very easy to have
working now because the streams
literally don't exist during capture.
Also, did they make the model like way
slower?
It used to be like way quicker on um on
pretty simple ops like this.
Yeah, literally it would have been
faster for me to do this. So, why the
[ __ ] am I typing into the ll
Oh, this is just moving them. Well,
that's fine.
And it's slower.
No, it's not. Wait.
I could have sworn I just had it train
with
Yeah, it trained right here. Okay.
Um,
It did train once.
So if it's unstable
Okay, the work this morning was still
kind of okay. This is like just
intellectual sewage
is what this is here. This is awful.
Why the [ __ ] is this in a lambda now?
What the [ __ ]
Why the
like ever would you do this?
No,
just nobody
How is this still not stable?
Like how?
Go nuts. I'm absolutely going to go
nuts. This crap.
keyboard.
Oops. What I do?
What have you missed? Just pain. Pain
and suffering.
Then you'll just remove torch. I'm
trying. That would be lovely.
I'm trying to like make this not be six
layers of nested functions garbage.
Um because the [ __ ] way the
cudigraphs work is awful.
It actually would have been faster for
me to rewrite Torch at this point, which
is the sad thing. And better.
We'll do that in Puffer 6. Lesson
learned.
There's no such thing as necessary evil
when it comes to software. It's just
like you'll have to deal with the
garbage forever if you don't just delete
I'm just not having a good time with
this at all today.
[ __ ]
If we at least get this to run, I can I
can get this cleaned up quickly because
like I know all the stupid [ __ ] that it
did and I can very easily fix that.
But we need the graph capture to
actually work.
I think this is CUDA graphs off, isn't
it? Nope. Still doesn't work. Lovely.
Well, I just don't even know how that's
possible.
It just must have [ __ ] something. I
don't know.
I mean, it's just like so sad that this
is
I mean, you're going to see by Puffer 6,
I think, when we've just deleted Torch,
you're going to end up with like half
the amount of code as if you were to
have done it with Torch, and it's going
to be 10 times faster than Torch at that
point. It's already like six or seven, I
think. It It's just so It's so
incredibly sad the lie that all of
modern software is where it's like
abstract more [ __ ] abstract more [ __ ]
Don't go down to low level. That's
scary. Just deal with the minations of
imbeciles that come up with stupid
abstractions that don't [ __ ] work.
How many hundred hours of my 29th year
of life am I going to have to waste
dealing with torches or [ __ ]
or doing any heavy lifting. We'll have
to replace their autograd, but that's
nowhere near as hard as you would think.
Like, you literally don't need autograd.
The entire concept of autobrad is just
like uh
you don't even need it.
Wait
a device synchronize. I don't do that.
idea is pretty useful.
Really? I've spent several hundred hours
learning how useless it is.
Heaven forbid you have to call your
ownbackward function.
course, autodip seems super useful when
you have a massive graph because every
single op is its own kernel that you
can't even find anywhere in the
codebase.
Why can't we just have a neural net
library by Nvidia? Why can't we just
have that? That would be great.
You know, it could be we could have a
library that's just kernels.cu
that has all the kernels you need.
That'd be great.
You've got to be [ __ ] me. Okay. How
the [ __ ] does this still not work?
And yeah, the Kiann kernels actually
work. If only we could see them and like
mix and match them.
OSS kernels. That's awesome. If we get
open source Nvidia, that'd be just
great.
Attempting to get uh cudigraphs.
I'm trying to change the way that we
like we do cudigraph so that it doesn't
hide so much bloody code behind like
several functions and it's just not a
good time.
It's just not a good time.
I'm honestly wondering if we just have
to go back to the um
if we have to just go back to the
previous version. How much stuff do I
change on here?
I think I changed a whole bunch of crap
here.
Well, this is just going to take me an
hour because like this thing takes
forever. And uh now this is the only way
I'm going to have to be able to get it
back into working state. And then from
there just have to try it again, I
suppose.
Every time I tried sonnet and it doesn't
work though, the chat is immediately
like, "Oh, well, you're using sonnet."
Even though this thing is clearly
stupid.
That might be it.
Hang on. That one might be it.
Um,
first
eight.
That was it. It literally just [ __ ] up
the board. Good job.
Great use of time. Stupid.
So stupid.
Yeah, I'm going for Martineis after this
[ __ ] Like [ __ ]
Better than an hour lost. Jess, I've
been live for eight hours and 15
minutes.
This in particular, I've been doing at
least the last two hours.
I like working long hours, but not when
it's complete and utter horseshit.
Okay.
I'm going to now I'm going to go through
and I'm going to do it a slightly
different way. I'm going to go through
and I'm going to use the CC tags thing
that I do and we're going to unfuck the
code. All right. Ready?
long hours. Yeah.
I mean, realistically, like
these aren't like these aren't even long
hours for me.
I've kind of just done like I've done
enough long hours when I was younger
that this is kind of just whatever.
But man, like being [ __ ] with for
hours on end is not On.
All of this for reference was to remove
one layer of extra functions.
Yeah, that's how much I care about
having this thing refactored nicely.
Because I know when you go look at a new
piece of code and you're trying to find
like, you know, PO loss logic and you
have to click through four layers of
functions to find it. You know, the code
base is [ __ ]
That's why I spend so long not doing
that.
Okay, this is the easy thing. Yes, easy
now. Very easy.
We're going to go get that comment as
well.
Oh, lovely. Scrolls me to the top for no
reason. Good.
It's funny when they say, "Oh, but like
the Claude app, we wrote Claude code
with the Claude with Claude." Yeah, I
can tell the app sucks. Keeps scrolling
me up randomly and flickers randomly
sometimes, too.
Yeah. Why did it just It's just scrolled
me all the way to the top. You see?
We'll do this.
Stupid, but that'll work.
I don't know why it's like this.
If this runs though,
if this trains at least this will be
very close and like I can actually go
look and figure out a lot of the cleanup
I think from here.
If this broke training I'm going to lose
my [ __ ]
Okay,
we are good. Also, we have 3 second
solves now.
Um,
yep, that's just 15 16 million step per
second training. Very cool. I'll be
back.
We're actually going to need to get a
harder benchmark because it's getting to
the point where um breakout gets solved
so fast that we don't even get to spin
up to full training speed before we
solve it.
Okay, we got 977 lines of code here.
But
uh we have less garbage.
I believe we have less garbage.
neural MMO benchmark too slow or rather
too hard like we need a 30 second
benchmark basically
we need a new like a new 30 second
benchmark.
It's got to be like a super fast end
that's hard enough that it takes us 30
seconds to solve.
Now we can find something in here
probably.
Ideally, it's something with relatively
short epochs as well because that also
messes up scoring. Like epochs at most
like a thousand steps would be good.
Uh I epochs I mean rollouts thousand
steps would be good.
Now we'll figure something. I think most
of the M's on here are going to be
solved sub 10 seconds with puffer 4.
Sparse maze. Yeah, we might end up doing
that. We'll see.
The thing is there are a lot of
different configurations of sparse maze.
It's not just like one task cleanly.
And also, I don't think sparse maze is
um it's like a good benchmark for some
types of stuff, but not for everything.
Let's make a quick commit before I screw
something up.
I don't want to lose this.
What time is it? 5.
I got about an hour before I got to go
to dinner.
About all the brain power I've got left
for today as well.
Let me see if there's any more highle
change that I think is required before
we start doing like the fine grain
stuff. It seems like this is still way
too long to me.
I mean, eight is one normal work day
and I do more than that.
It's like a week western work today.
It's actually this is pretty nice. like
this.
I think we just do fine grain on that
and we're good.
Same here.
I don't like how we have this if else
because of the profile. H no, that's
actually kind of okay, I think.
Okay, so this is
this is only 590 lines in and we had
some stuff at the top. So 500 lines for
all this and then we have this massive
ass create function right
This is Bflat buffers
states graphs graphs graphs graphs
restore weight
streams
tensor close
like jank jank. Okay,
I think we are actually kind of ready
for the fine grained
Do we want this inlined? Actually,
no. I think we'll actually leave this
for testing.
I'm trying to think if I want to leave
these just sea style nice like this.
Probably do, right?
But wait, did this get used?
Uh, do you actually use this
capturing
Do you see it in here? I don't see it in
here.
Apparently this is in here. Advantage
mean advantage variance.
How do you get focused on this one
project and not get distracted?
Cuz it's all just [ __ ] noise. It
doesn't matter.
I mean, do you really care about the
stupid status games people are playing
at the expense of like real
technological progress?
Like most of the AI [ __ ] around is like
really not serious anything. It's all
just hype and drift. It's not why I got
into AI. AI used to be like a way a way
more serious technical field.
Of course, it also didn't work. But
like I basically know that if I just
keep doing this for the next year or
two, I will have this entire area of
science stable, mature, broadly applied
like
tremendous, tremendous amount of
progress.
Did I already get down to here? I didn't
think I did. Hang on. Yeah. No, we're
still up here.
Oh, I think we're actually going to be
able to go full deterministic as well,
which would be cool.
Okay, we're going to have to figure out
all this stuff. Um, this like select of
narrow whatever the hell.
This is kind of ubiquitous.
I don't have a good way to deal with
that yet though.
Those
will get deleted.
massive ass signature on computer train
loss
unfortunately. Yes.
Not happy about it.
I don't want to touch that though.
That's fiddly.
And then this thing here, I actually
don't know what it is needed. And that's
like horribly unstable. So there
I hate that I have to use freaking claws
so much for this cleanup, but holy hell,
this is just so garbage, garbage,
garbage. And I want this to not be
garbage, garbage, garbage.
I think I'm just not going to release
this until I'm I naturally find myself
not wanting to use Claude on the code.
Because if I want to use Claude on the
code, it's because the code sucks.
I don't want to use freaking Claude when
I'm doing my own ends.
It's super easy.
It's only when I'm dealing with a bunch
of [ __ ]
I can't wait for them to be embodied so
I can body one.
You guys basically got the whole list
backwards.
That's impressive.
He doesn't know what a greater than sign
means.
Uh, what do we do?
Right.
And then in the meantime, we have a
problem we can think about. We have
several little refactor problems we can
think about, right? Instead of just
sitting here being lazy.
The main one I wanted to figure out
these narrow ops. this select narrow
copy pattern. It's kind of crap, right?
Like look at this network call here.
This function is actually very simple,
but it looks very complicated because
the syntax is a mess, right?
I don't know if that's going to be um
it's probably got some annoying overhead
or some [ __ ] knowing torch.
There's dot slice dim start plus length.
Keep the dimension.
Oh, I have 13 notifications.
Well, the notifications are like backed
up today.
Yeah, it's funny.
It's like
the 10 minute long dips are like an
inside joke.
Look, I gotta wait. I gotta walk all the
way downstairs. I got to wait for water
to boil. I got to make my tea. I got to
get upstairs.
You try screaming for freaking nine
hours without having to get up to do
stuff. Actually, don't. That's kind of
terrible for you.
At least I got to go up and down the
stairs a few times.
It's going to take another couple
passes, but
Okay. So, there's three things here.
Curiosity 900 lunch.
Okay.
Why are we deleting my profiling
functions?
and then this last one will be slightly
irritating everything.
So, we're removing VF-16 as a flag um
from the settings because it's now
compile time,
which actually makes the code a little
bit simpler.
that's fine. It has to use the um the
torch dypes for this.
It's fine.
and it's fine. There is a little bit of
conditional logic. No big deal.
Horrifying internal compiler. Lovely.
Favorite
I like the reason I'm doing this is
because I think we're basically there.
Like I think we basically have it uh to
here. There's probably like just one or
two small sources of randomness.
I suppose the um
the environments
since the environments are threaded, it
could be a little weird.
Oh, it's going to return like the native
path. We don't need the native path to
be deterministic. Just the colonel's
path.
Fully deterministic cranium back end
would be so nice.
There is probably my guess would be
threaded. Um,
I say
and are
Okay,
we can do this.
It's pretty cool.
That's so ass. Okay, we'll just do this
one.
This should be easy.
You see what I'm trying to do, Right.
Like,
oh, I should make a nice commit. I
should make a quick commit on this.
Yeah, let's do that for
It just has one rand call on reset, I
believe. Makes it a really nice good uh
nice thing for testing.
Uh, okay. So, you the MP false is no
good.
This is now going to do multinnomialist
thing.
That's interesting. We broke um
broke Infernal path apparently. All
right.
I'm pretty happy with the progress
overall, even though it was a pain in
the ass for several hours.
I mean, there's still some stuff like
this where this is annoying.
Obviously, the bottom of this file is
still a mess.
No custom kernels. 8 mil.
Funny enough though, it doesn't train
because of um be float with torch
kernels.
Isn't that funny?
That doesn't make any sense anyways
though.
Let's see how the uh training Run to run
54.
should be developed in three. Yep. It's
going to be very very similar. Liberty
finish stream soon. I've been live
almost 10 hours
I think this is probably unlikely to
work, right?
I mean, what do we think, folks? Like,
is it worth adding one additional
uh one additional thing to the buffer
API spec to improve RNG?
Because
We're not going to be able to get it
full deterministic.
Let's just see what the variances with
this.
Now, see, there's still plenty of
variance.
I'm just seeing if we can get
determinism out of the end out of the
library into the library.
Oh, wait. 829 382.
Okay, it's still not deterministic.
We'll play with it. I don't know if it's
going to be a realistic thing to have,
but it would be super nice if we could
do it.
I think it probably
uh it's probably not something we should
do right now, though.
So, we'll leave this be. Uh, I got to go
get dinner. So, thank you folks for
tuning into the stream.
probably won't do a stream later unless
I'm for whatever reason feel like super
motivated to do another two hour stream
after 10 hours of stream already. Um, if
you want to help me out for absolutely
free, just feed the puffer star on
GitHub. It's like less than 20 stars off
of 5K. It's rounding up. It'd be really,
really awesome to hit 5,000 stars this
weekend on the project.
If you want to get involved with
development, join the Discord. If you
want more reinforcement learning
content, follow me on X. This is where
all of the educational articles are
going to be and all like the research
stuff I produce uh from Puffer Forro
will be on here. So, thank you all and
uh have a nice weekend. I will be
backstreaming a little bit on